[Music]
even in Fantastic Pixar cartoons nobody
can aim for this is all well and good
but someone driving alongside on the
street could easily figure out your
identity if they noticed you before you
did this or even remember your car your
identity is toast mr. incredible why
doesn't he just laid the tree down on
the ground Jesus the guy stops a train
later with his bare hands
so he doesn't need the tree and as it
turns out unpredictable chase ended up
going down the perfect Street for mr.
incredible - stop it give me your number
one fan this move doesn't work out any
better for incredible way than it did
for me at Taylor Swift's New England
estate which is why in about 15 years
Taylor Swift is going to be really sorry
once I unleash all my evil inventions
how the hell did mr. incredible know
this dude was on top of this roof all he
heard was that there was a tour bus
robbery in progress he obviously didn't
get there while it was happening but he
got there in time to see the robber
running away I guess but didn't catch up
to him until he ran all the way to the
top of a building and not just one but
two superheroes tracked and found this
asshole now you just stay here they
usually pick up the garbage in an hour
on the roof mr. incredible accidentally
saved someone into the scene of another
crime he can stop so I guess this
Minister knows their secret identity
nearly all the wedding guests are
dressed in their superhero office which
is odd considering you think proper
wedding attire would be called forward
even here they took a risk this guy
wouldn't say anything which is kind of
amazing you and your son can go now mrs.
Park did the principal ask her to come
out here without looking at the tape
first isn't just a little possible
someone would see that especially since
the most popular kid in school just
happens to be around in that same area
man that kid is writing the Quietus big
wheel in existence you must have that
caterpillar drive from the Red October
no I gotta pay to fix it a card table
you broke a plate dude not a table man
you are distracted Jesus why is it that
none of the kids in this family have the
same powers as their parents you think
genetically with three kids that'd be at
least one and you'd think even if they
had different powers each would have
either elasticity or super strength or
some combination also will bring up the
Fantastic Four elephant in the room
since half the characters have the same
powers and you could even make a case
mr. incredible is a non monster read the
thing that least - who's just the flash
as a kid so we'll send that but for all
the people who are down on this because
it's an animated Fantastic Four
when's the last time you saw a Fantastic
Four movie that was even good much less
as good as this
well this article on the right is a bull
the first two sentences are about a
shooting the rest is copy pasted from
the ensure care insurance employee
manual and
article on the far left is obviously
also copy pasted from the Insurance
manual awesome but that's still spit it
can't be a superhero movie in the early
2000s without heroes saving people from
a burning building
both these superheroes use the rescued
fire victims as shields during this
debris shower thankfully for our heroes
only one cop bursts into the store right
now while the others wait outside to see
if he dies and oh he fired his gun maybe
we should go help that single cop we
send in to capture the jewel thieves all
by himself what am I going to do about
my husband face in a world where
superpowers are real physical injuries
as a result of superpowers are not real
also luckily this happens right at the
time when mr. incredible has another job
offer waiting for him when he gets home
we gotta pay damages erase memories
relocate your family wait hold up you
can erase memories and if you can erase
memories why do you need to relocate the
family message this Brad Bird steals the
mission impossible' from a franchise he
will one day direct do residential homes
have water sprinklers convenient jungle
waterless slip and slide since later we
see this thing has propeller arms why is
it not using said propeller arms right
now this molten lava causes no damage
whatsoever to the omnijoin mr.
incredible uses my older brothers stop
hitting yourself method to defeat the
robots also how lucky is he to not be
hit by any of this robot self harm bolt
and invited him to dinner why so he can
witness the llama wall thing he'll use
later to infiltrate your secure computer
room is there any other reason I take it
our host is Zeus a mirage and mr.
incredible are definitely not this close
and not close enough to have a normal
conversation for sure and that is a
waterfall of lava how can they even
remotely hear each other at all good
thing this train yard is entirely
deserted all day every day so that no
one ever sees this why is he cleaning he
got that one gig and got paid but Mirage
gave no indication he'd have more work
in the future
I mean sure maybe he's just trying to
feel better about his body and that's
cool but with workouts in the new cars
movie suggests sabab somehow knows he'll
have more superhero work coming oh no
wait there's a train which is fine and
all but no one else here I mean if
trains are coming through here then
there have to be workers all over this
train yard right stray hair on a jacket
always means your man is cheating cliche
also has he not clean that thing since
he got a Mirage hair on it that was
months ago right and Helen didn't notice
this until now also right after she
finds the stray hair guess who's calling
right now
hello we have a new assignment for you
first time they sent a self-destructing
iPad second mission regular ask phone
call direct to this family's home phone
line because security right I mean this
is ultimately what gets Helen curious
enough to go after Bob later
so syndromes outfit sloppy mission
delivery really cost his own demise if
you think about it by the way you're
getting bang three ways to Sunday lately
and you think he's cheating on you he
didn't get you to do anything asshole
and just because you're self-aware about
the monologue you can doesn't make it
right does it
try this one on for size big boy if you
wanted to kill him couldn't you have
done that already well if not for this
handy underground cave mr. incredible is
a dead man
yeah thank God for this Islands fluky
geography this is the worst goddamn life
sensing probe ever created doesn't have
any proof of mr. incredible being dead
unless it got fooled by the convenient
gazer beam skeleton down in the cavern
even so how did it miss mr. incredible
right behind the skeleton can also
withstand the temperature over 1,000
degrees
yes but can the baby's face let's go do
what get that asshole radio it in
luckily Mirage just happens to be
looking down and has no peripheral
vision whatsoever as mr. incredible
holds a giant statue over his head well
that's awesome that mr. incredible was
able to use that password that geezer
beam just happened to carve into the
cavern walls with his last dying breath
but how did gazer beam learn that damn
password also super genius syndrome uses
a six letter password for the computer
that holds the secret to all his island
operations it's pretty ridiculous that
all these superheroes died and there
wasn't one word about it through their
network sure they may have gotten out of
touch over the years but all these
people dying and not even a whisper
about it incredible firebase garbage
disposal here but what have you
accidentally bumped dinner into this
thing shouldn't the fire at least beat
button activated encouragement abuse
abuse admit take that off before
somebody sees who's going to see it
you're in a bedroom where you just
closed all the blinds
snug I'm calling in a solid you owe me
it's no ex machina you know I was right
to idolize you
I I always knew you were tough but
tricking the probe by hiding out of the
bones of another super oh man maybe it
shouldn't be mr. Incredibles amazing
trick you're amazed by the horrible
failure of your probe to detect it
besides hiding under where is he hiding
under also how the fuck do you know
that's what he did your probe didn't
notice him
did you send another better probe after
the fact or did you have video cameras
down there thereby negating the reason
for the probe the kids stowed away which
is cute so you think about how they did
it I mean only one of them can turn
things invisible and yet they somehow
arranged a sitter in seconds snuck into
the car before mom for a ride to the
airport snuck onto the plane and then
stayed quiet this whole time it would
certainly suck if these missiles hit the
jet but considering what Edna said about
their super suits being indestructible
would it really be on that bad they
probably survived that which we would
then sent yep this rules one sin off
kind of rules Elastigirl kicks this dude
who accidentally starts shooting
everywhere and wait shooting the keycard
access thing makes the door open well
that's convenient I guess it's a good
thing - decided to check this cave out
at this very moment in time or else they
would have been toast unless those suits
are is awesome and Sedna says they are
where your very face doesn't get burned
somehow that's how freakin far the
flames went why doesn't - just do the
thing he did a minute ago when they
don't ran the fireball and take his
sister by the hand and zoom the hell
outta range from the spy bird syndrome
still hasn't killed mr. incredible for
some reason there actually is no use for
mr. incredible anymore so the only
reason why he's still here is just so he
could be saved by his family
of course look I don't care how awesome
these little jungle speeder things are
they aren't catching up to the - we've
seen in this movie - is that Doogie
Howser graduate of the Prometheus school
of running away from things the
screenwriters bless - with four times as
much luck as he deserved in this
sequence to ensure he landed on this ex
machina Island security chopper
premature jubilation and Brad Bird loves
the bullets whizzing into the water
effect doesn't he I mean we know these
bullets would lose most of their power
once they hit the water but as shown
damn that girl should be dead you
married
elastic girl how do you not know that
after following Bob around all this time
okay so maybe you don't recognize her
because she doesn't ever mask on but
you've got Mirage to do some hardcore
stalking and she knew what Bob looked
like without his mask on so I don't get
your surprise at all
and with everyone super no one will be
why are they still alive again syndrome
tried to create a perfect superhero
killing robot but accidentally invented
AI which surprisingly the movie slides
right on by without a second thought
what are you Ricky
violet recovers from unconsciousness
just at the time she needs to reinsert
herself back into the action why are
there no labels on this remote that
explains what each one does and that's
an elementary stuff right there
but syndrome decided now I can memorize
it the only thing hard enough to
penetrate it is yeah but I thought
syndrome built an upgrade to the robot
you destroyed and wouldn't that be part
of the upgrade you mean this is actually
gonna work this is some incredible
ending by mr. incredible here to take
out the robots brain core considering he
couldn't see the core and the claw
rocket changed directions after he let
go of it you mean after he got slammed
into the building and fell unconscious
he got up and went to the par household
because why again only here did he first
learn bob was married and had these two
kids but he didn't know anything about
Jack Jack so what the hell it's no one
else in the neighborhood besides big
wheel kid concerned about this huge
disturbance this Underminer just starts
blathering away immediately
so he's positive someone important we'll
be right there outside the elementary
school track to hear him and being on
I'm pretty sure I would have figured out
these people's secret identities by now
oh by the way one last thing did we
mention how much this movie steals all
the James Bond this movie steals all the
James Bond
doesn't it bother you all the worlds and
innocent people you've helped destroy
[Music]
you find something comical about my
appearance when I'm driving my
automobile Jenny today I quit my job and
then I told my boss to go fuck himself
and then i blackmailed him for almost
$60,000 Pastis paragraph you have a
problem with authority in Sanderson you
believe that you are special that
somehow the rules do not apply to you
obviously you are mistaken elevator
dinah guys stag on takeoff splashdown
sucked into a vortex nuggets well it is
good Cape weather cool reason why a cape
who wears a cape where do you even get a
cape you've beaten my giant which means
you're exceptionally strong so you could
have put the poison in your own goblet
resting on your strength to save you so
I can clearly not choose the wine in
front of you you know what I do I
connect I get people off I look for the
one guy who isn't getting off and I make
him get off and with everyone's super
maniacal laugh no one will be how can
this be for the greater good
[Music]
[Laughter]